hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bendy in the ink machine
no when I first saw this game it
reminded me of the old-school Disney
animation days you know back when they
made Willy Steamboat Willie and all that
stuff so it has something to do with
old-school animation and putting ink on
paper dear Henry it seems like a
lifetime since we worked on cartoons
together thirty years really slips away
doesn't it if you're back in town come
visit the old workshop there's something
I need to show you your best pal Joey
Drew alrighty then I'll trust you Joey
drew I don't know what you have in store
for me oh that's a cute little guy now I
don't know if this is in any way to do
with horror at all but seems to have a
Darby curve I'm here alright man this is
a weird place
the dancing demon oh good old bendy I
didn't think that this was a horror game
when I was going into it but holy [ __ ]
bendy and sheep songs with Boris the
wolf okay then hello what am I supposed
to find here in this horrifying place of
decrepid miss uh hi hello you a lovely
projector
great that's a good sign are you doing
bendy you good well I'm very good okay
then
hold animation board blank storyboards
weird to film reels on the walls don't
know why those are there oh what's that
say dreams come true you talking about
bendy coming to life hi how are you
doing
did bendy come true oh that's a dark
ominous hallway I know a dark ominous
hallway when I see it Oh
tastes like ink and blood mixed together
very bad stuff how many Bendis are here
ink machine okay I don't know if that
means why I'm going towards it okay I
don't know if that's the first thing
that I'd wonder about that I'd wonder
about the horror things going on in here
oh it's not good at all everyone's gonna
die yeah okay let's turn on the horrible
monstrosity that's definitely gonna kill
me okay wrench do you help weird chests
no drawers do you help also this is the
first video that I've been able to
record since we just did a date with
markiplier and I wanted to say thank you
guys so much for the amazing response on
that video I'll talk about it more when
I have more time to talk about it but I
just wanted to say it's been a slog and
I finally took a day off yesterday where
I did absolutely nothing because we've
been working on that not non-stop for
about a week and a half
whoa-ah doesn't seem natural over there
I think I see inky limbs and an exposed
ribcage so that's nice oh yeah yeah I
think he's trying to make wolfy whoo oh
that's horrifying
oh no oh boy okay that's weird that's
Boris the wolf who don't look so good I
don't know who Joey is or what Joey was
doing but there's a lot of death
happening here yeah it's it's kind of
out of context just thank you guys so
much for the support we worked so hard
on that we're very happy for the way it
turned out
oh boy main power okay let's whip this
bad boy into shape ain't worried about
nothing going on here the bread oh I
thought there was a reason all those
items were strewn about all over the
place Oh put this here okay all right
then glad you vocalized the jump scare
for me so I didn't even have to think
about what I was feeling all right
who's laughing now I don't know if
anybody's laughing I'm definitely do
laughing all right but anyway just good
lord Louie I think I know where
everything was I've seen them on the way
in here so I just got to find him and
then somehow I got a turn on the ink
machine probably when I already uh okay
got bad that's nice that's real good so
probably I'll be able to turn on the ink
of Sheen once I get all the power up I
can't sprint so this is my max speed at
the moment but uh let me just go back
and get everything that I needed dreams
come true they sure do you buddy boo
they sure do that oh here we go I didn't
even know that I was the thing kind of
forgot what I was supposed to be getting
but I got that squeak ooh plushie doll
[ __ ] you guys why are you so loud and
obnoxious oh I don't know what else I
saw around here so I guess I just got to
keep exploring until I find everything
I've got three which is good but I need
more anything over here desk wasted so
much time in this chair wave this desk
at the end of a hallway you're not even
in your own room you don't even have a
window okay no all right then cool okay
I'm not gonna ask many questions about
it but you know what maybe that's for
the best
I'm gonna find the [ __ ] and hopefully
aha got another one the illusion of
living
that's a weird book to read casually so
I've got 4 of 6 items at least something
isn't chasing me and giving me that
trope but this is fascinating here this
is just weird
I like I love the cartoony style but
also it doesn't make a lot of sense you
know if my boss told me that I needed to
sacrifice desk objects to appease the
gods I might have a few more questions
then if another pipe bursts yeah okay
then I guess if you really thought about
what could they do
[Music]
ah Oh lovely
Oh lovely flow in pressure okay so I
probably got to come here last by still
got to find exactly what I'm looking for
I don't see anything in here that I need
oh it automatically places them for me
oh that's convenient okay so I need an
ink bottle I need a cogwheel and that's
it
so just an ink bottle and a cogwheel but
those should probably be on someone's
desk for drawing maybe mine actually oh
there's a cogwheel well got that all
right so ink well must be on someone's
desk which might be mine if I was gonna
be poetic about this oh okay sorry to
disturb you all carry on oh there it is
goddamn that took forever
okay restoring pressure which is okay I
wonder what switch it could be huh all
right then Kurt chuckles maybe any day
now could I do this this is not what I
can do okay I need to restore the ink
flow oh I know where that is it's a long
way around the wrong way way that I
should have been going before but you
made me sidetrack myself so that I
couldn't complete what I needed to do
fine
hi how are you doing okay I wasn't ready
for that but I'm ready now
oh you all fight huh you walk out all
right oh hey buddy
hey bendy are you doing bendy I don't
know how the flow is all the way over
here but you know you have a nice day
you have a lovely day
yeah hey buddy are you doing sorry did i
disturb something that's not good sounds
okay oh it sounds like something's come
behind me that's okay
I'm not worried it's just the couch
uncles of all things flowing I guess I
don't know how this entire place is
powered by peer Inc but uh good for it
good for it good for it ah that's goofy
the gods have accepted my sacrifice of
random [ __ ] items okay
all right
so now I guess I can turn on the ink
machine whatever the hell that means
whatever the hell that door [ __ ] okay
I'll get out of here then goodbye
now I'm skedaddling oh now I'm running
now that was a long fall the creator
lied to us okay all right then I'll take
this bad boy here this year definitely
come in handy oh hell yeah I'm sure that
ink monsters are specifically
susceptible to axes can I ask you a
question
Capri bad get your packs body spray yeah
if okay all right then risky risky have
rear hub raskin okay where am I now in
the old animation studio after then
support chapter two oh okay well that's
not too bad so that's pretty good I mean
this game only costs one dollar but that
was surprisingly well made I really did
enjoy that that was not bad at all um
for what it was though in the first
chapter it's not a lot of game though
because I mean I get it the game is $1
but this might as well be a demo in my
opinion there was a lot of good stuff
here I love the environment I love the
cartoonish aspect of it and you opened
the door for a lot of stuff but hard to
define an entire chapter with that but
either way still not bad I liked it a
lot I can't wait to see what happens in
chapter 2 so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments below and
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]